Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Astroneer.
I'm here with Wolfie, say hi!
W: Hi!
Now Wolfie, I met at Pax about a year ago. Pax, uh, prime, which is now known as Pax West right?
W: Yeah.
Yeah, and so we met through the, the Make-A-wish program,
And we were gonna do a collab here and, don't ask me why I took nine months,
Because I was supposed to,
*Mark giggles*
I was supposed to do this much sooner, heh,
W: We're both busy people here!
Right, we're busy people,
W: We gotta decide, we gotta chop up our days
Yeah,
So I'll get into the the what why and what we're doing here as soon as I can figure out how to frickin' control this
Because I can't get the music to go down. It's so dumb.
Okay, alright, so I'm going to launch waboo
Oh, whoops I didn't launch. I forgot that doesn't want you that man goes to a loading screen oops, okay?
Then I'm gonna invite you to my game like the invite the game did you get an invite?
W:Yes, I did alright.How do I view?  never tell your password to anybody M:shift and tab M:yep, W:never tell your password to anyone
Tell me your password boom. I don't know the password. You don't have a password. You expect me to believe it
um
It's usually something very very like you can't decipher. It penis fucker six nine
Is that it that's really close, but it's actually nine six. Oh penis fucker nine six.
You almost hit the nail on the head M:ah man. It's because I know yeah. I know W:yeah, yeah.
W:Yeah, you knew what I was thinking M:okay So anyway
We're playing Astroneer again number one because there's been a lot of updates to the game and number two like I mentioned
Wolfie, and I met through the Make-A-wish foundation, and if you wanted to talk about
You know what's going on in the *stutters*
in the immediate future because you have to go on dialysis very soon. Don't you?
Yeah, I do um oh wait a second. Can I just launch and I'll meet you yeah come on down
I thought you were already here click which ones. No. I finally loaded back up. I'm gonna be big Bobblehead astronaut. Oh, yeah
I am I
Have a kidney
What is it called? I have a kidney problem
I guess would be the best way to sum it up
and what happens is that my membranes are clogged because there's somewhat of 23 in each kidney and
oh, wow, that's loaded bad and
Yeah, I'm landing yay Gotta play. Oh
God
You don't know right lay-oh. Hi. Oh hello. I said I was gonna be a bobble head uh-huh. Yeah, okay? Oh
Don't point at me. Oh you dare come how do I get anything out um but I am
Recently my kidney function is dropped ooh ooh, I got it. I figured it out. It's eight to 12 percent and
That was roughly two weeks ago, so it's probably below that now
and
Whether I want to or not, I don't really have a choice whether to go on dialysis or not
And then hopefully in the near future I can get it on my mind. Sorry
Thank you. You only get one though just know that. I tell everybody when they sneeze you only get one oh
Thank you for being so generous with those bless yous I appreciate that very much. You're welcome anytime all right?
So do you know you never played this game before though right? No?
Oh, God so much cool different than that noel. Don't you worry about it thing? I'm an
Expert at this so just I can run don't don't run hang on wait
I forget how to I forget out of not do something like that. I'm an expert. How do I do this oh?
Hey, okay. Wow that was those weirdly snake-like and girls out at me. Yeah
Yeah, I saw that though came right up to my face in this game
You have to go and collect resources and then build structures with which to be able to build what you need to build make sense
Sort of yeah, okay
I'll go on the ground with your terrain tool like see this resin over here if you mouse over it you can left click on
It and you'll start sucking it up into your gun
Just like that
now you
Want to always make sure that you suck a full stack out of there because if you don't suck a full stack with you start
Sucking something else. You'll lose what you were stacking
So you always got to make sure you get a full stack of the thing that you actually want not just goofin
Uganda I got it there you go. You know what you're doing
Yeah, you can also get these plants here to get more stuff
You got plant materials, and then if you hit cue you'll go into your backpack
And then you can make certain items like a solar panel is very nice because that way you get more power
So you can suck more makes any compound for everything exactly air
You got to go out we got to get compound, so you need to wait
You have what you put resident there? I don't know. I I had some fine. Whatever I put residue. Oh
Yeah, did you build a research stage had it in my head? I knew it was Gonna happen
I just didn't tell you because I knew before you did dude stop acting confident you
Don't know what's going on and neither do I okay so that build?
These that built something that it's like a standard template
Construct it can build a printer it can build a smelter it can build a vehicle bake and build a research station
So the one thing that we probably need to do first is the real what are you doing? I?
Just wanted to try this
we
need
Alright, so we need to we need to get more compound, but to do that
We need to have very set of things so actually let me see if I can desert whale I can trade with you or something
Okay, I'm dropping this compound on the ground you see that there. God. Yeah, you picked it up. I got it hit pew
And the bottom flip over until you see small solar
Hmm. Yes, you're going to want it alive. You're gonna want to build that
Okay, there you go
So now you got a solar panel on your backpack which means that you're gonna be able to get more help
It's nighttime uh is it though is it I?
Don't I'll just look up is it though?
Yes, is it. I'm confident in that much okay. I know the sun. I've been staring at it for a while
Okay, good for you
That's not what you're supposed to be doing but they are supposed to come up
Dramatically at that point because I think it's almost daytime, but if you come with me
We're going to go on an expedition
And there's going to be dangerous because we only have a certain amount of oxygen if we run out of oxygen
We die make sense pretty much, okay, cool glad we're on the same page here
And oh the sun is about to come up how cool is that?
It's so lucky that I found a solar panel by myself. Yeah, you did it all by yourself
You're such a good good good ass no fifty percent oxygen. What do I do? Well? We should probably get back
Okay, so this was uh what what this is here. This is a wreck so the wrecks usually contain
Researchable things they're big old Bulbous things that you got to drag back over to a research station
Don't you build that yeah? You better come back. We're about to run out of oxygen and die that's no good I
Wasn't paying attention. Yeah, you should pay attention pretty much. That's what you should definitely do yeah run alignment way lower oxygen than you
I'm suffocating because you me you're brenton. You're supposed to be all kinds of rationing here. We go there
We go and no, I'm not going to give you my breath no it's my breath
I could have died good then you would have learned a lesson all right
So the second lesson is I would just come back. Maybe we would have convicted
Lesson is there's resources all over the place
You need to look for the Rocky white ones that kind of look like not the not the blue
Dildo like ones you need the ones over here that are rocks
These are calm the clouds above or the rocks ahead down on the ground stop staring up at the stars
You need to actually understand the problems that are down here on Earth
So go over to that other guy and gather that one see this one over here
And they don't run try not to run you can run if you want
I mean you got enough oxygen right here
But just to gather up as much compound as you can because compound in the beginning of the game is the most
Important thing that you can possibly have because it's used to build the majority of the things we're going to be using make sense
Make that and now the sun's up the solar panel is going to be working you see how that's useful
What are we going to use compound for though?
I literally just said come on the thing that gets here the most build to the build thing and what I just
Died did I not just say I understand now. I'm done suffocating all right
I'm going to build a research station you bring back that stuff and don't die. That's the rule number one. Oh
Don't give me that um mmM, and I break rule number one. Oh cows suffocating. Why would you break rule number one?
can we
bring air
Yeah, actually I was just about to get to that if you would let me actually be me and how smart I am you would
Have realized how great. I am so if you watch this I made what are called tethers now with tethers
We can extend our effective range of oxygen you see these blue lines
Yeah, you connect them out and these are like little beacons of oxygen
They will keep us alive as we go out and explore and then we can pick them up you oaky astronaut. Thank you
Wait, you were me
Me no, I'm your like a slim fit one. Why do you think I keep running out of breath? I don't know
Cuz it look at me. I'm gonna be gold booking if you got so much muscle
You need to actually move it around it's it's a dwell. Yeah
Yeah, see I know I got you back okay, so what I'm heading for right now is in the distance
I see pillars of compound and these pillars. Oh, this is a lot of resin right here
You might want to gather up this stuff because there's a lot of good at it. You got the resin. Okay you get that redbull
Forget about will need resin later
But there are oodles of compound over here that I'm going for and these things are going to really really get our scurred stuff
oh, oh
Such glorious suckage. Oh
My seconds, but I'm getting there. I'm not a master. Oh
Yeah, that's okay because over here on the left you can see oh watch out for the precipice
There's a cave over here
And it is a big drop and I don't know how you'd get that one field just be careful about it
Just be careful about it. Oh God. Oh jeez. Oh, it. Just looks like a big big puddle in the ground
Yeah, don't you drop in
Alright, okay too many items so over here you have too many items. Oh all that resin, okay?
What we can do eventually will create storage stuff
But let me let me fill up on what I need I'm going to get the rest of this
Compound and then we'll make a trip back
and then we'll have a good amount of resources to
Be able to do everything that we need to do so give me a one second. I'm going to try to
Yeah, I think it sounds like a pretty good plan
I'm glad that you know I didn't elect you, but you chose to be the leader yeah well
I mean as the one who is played with before and is obviously the
Better of us it's Gonna be me gonna bein a don't bust out in God. That's only art okay
That's a second episode skill you you know
Buster steps out into song you got a yeah build into that. It takes like this yeah yeah, we came far
Yeah, yeah, we didn't let me get one more stack of resin and then I'm going to okay alright
So I'm full up on stuff. We're going to leave those
Tezur0
More tethers later, but once we get back. I'm going to show you how to build more
Storage facility so that we can be able to build what we need to build and then eventually we're going to be able to build
a Frickin vehicle make sense
Noise noise. I know it's much what why why can I put this stuff on the back of this this is storage?
It's just storage anything you see like that is just storage so what I'm building here is I'm building another
Bay and we're going to build a vehicle bay right here makes ends cool great, but we need aluminum for that
I forgot about that
So what we need to do first is we need to build a smelter to be able to build
Copper ore so this is our smelter make sense great
Shouldn't we have storage first you have a sword you got to pay attention. See you're not paying attention
see if you go to cue
You can drag something out of your inventory into any of those red little circles there make sense the excess of that aw shit
I dropped it. Why'd you drop? It? Don't drop it. I can't I got it. You got to click twice
Nobody told me about this. Hey if fuckin
Everything is a double click until proven otherwise, okay, that's good skills for life
That's a lifeless that is the life lesson and Markiplier provides life lessons
101 with Markiplier like life 101 with Mark one
Alright, so we don't have much compound, but we got a lot of resin so we got to go back and get more compound
But I don't think there was any more on the way over there
But what we can do is we can go into the cave yeah, are you ready to go into the cave?
Let's do that the answer is no, you're not ready to go into the cave because you have no idea how to survive
So I'm gonna show you how to go into a goddamn cave okay, so come with me
I always need an adult yeah you here's the scary thing you are an adult. Oh
Goodness, I know right oh
Gosh Terror fine nobody called me. Well, you're not quite an adult. How old are you I'm actually 19
Yeah, you're an adult. That's all you were an adult
Yeah, so you suck it up, and you come with me in this cave. Make sense all right
That sounds good. So here's where the dangerous thing is see this this hole here. You're gonna have to jump in there
Okay
Now your draw you're gonna die ha ha ha all right. I'll jump in there with you, but before I do that
I'm gonna set up the tethers which you should have done because remember I was telling you about the tethers how important they were oh
That god oh your ex where I died. It's just showing like you died. How did it die I?
Jumped in a hole well, and then how'd you die I don't know I just kind of laid there and fell asleep
And I guess I don't know what
That's real quick. Well you didn't did you jump in? No? I didn't jump in because I'm not an idiot well
I did I thought you jumped in it didn't die and that's why you were like why why did you know I?
Still don't know. How did you what killed you oh?
What?
Really string. Oh, man. I didn't know you could take fall damage. I have no idea
I guess you had no idea no cuz I had no idea. Why would I have an idea?
Don't hit, but I thought it was like. Oh, no. We're on a moon type thing you can land well
Nah, that is probably not the case
so help me excavate the ground because what I'm trying to do here is I'm trying to create like a
Level path for us to get down there. Geez you know what I mean, it's literally like nothing below us
This is Gonna be triage. You're just an entire cavern
Nah, nah, there's a wall. There's a wall where I'm digging just by digging here. Yeah, dig where I'm digging just keep making a trough
mmm
Nice that big sonic that that's where the compound reservoir was it's nothing right now
Hey, dig yeah, I told you to dig it. You're a dd. Are you hearing me dig there you go?
That's helpful. Yeah there you go. I go in now. Well. I still die Rona. I'll be the test well, okay
All right, let me put some feathers down wow. Oh I slid in tell me there's me out you better. Take me alive
Oh goddammit. You better dig me out here. I mean, I got tethers, so I'm fine
Whoo oh gosh this kazon. Oh this cave is horrifying oh good. There's power down here. So that's good
Can't suck there. We go tips not a fighting turbine capable nuts. Okay, okay? Okay? Why don't you just come on down?
Well there your solo phil thinks I was sucking, but you weren't you weren't sucking then who was sucking all right?
We'll get it later. There's more power here. I'm just gonna dig out a crevice here
This is something this a nice calm thing. Oh the yellow stuff
That's power so it's basically like portable power you you suck it up, and it's an item. I don't work
It's like a battery stop. It's the future stop questioning everything all right
hydrazine
hydrazine that is a
flammable gas used for Rocket fuel
Thanks n. I got a big I got a big old. That's a researchable now
I'm going to grab on a scavenge from your corpse, and I'm going to get your shit and
One of us had to do it. It would horrify me to see my dead face
Yeah, it should I mean I'm horrified to see your live face
Exactly why do you think I were to tell mit? I don't know
I'm gonna put it up there all right
So I'm gonna keep building tethers out into this cave because there's a lot of goodies scoop up the power when you can
But don't fill your inventory because we got a lot more. I'm leaving. What are you leaving?
I got a do research. I gotta be more smarter well, okay you go research
I'll be down in this cave. If you hear screaming that means I'm dying
okay, don't come from the awesome one cold calls go by
You think I'm Gonna come for you
I mean, I'm the same I'll just call someone else and they can deal with and then I'll be like was he life
Was he alive I like how they used what they didn't. They don't even say is the alive not was he
What was he I got? I dropped it. Oh wow
great job there if I'm using
Telekinesis, it's my first time all of the sun, so pretty yeah, well, it's dark down here
So maybe you could come help this cavern. He'll have been huge. Oh so bright this cavern. I don't like it anymore enormous
oh my got in the research thing, okay yeah, then activate the research thing and
then
Continue down with me. I'm out of I got to build more tethers here, man. I'm building a lot of tethers I
Can't yet? I think we need like power or something we need power. What do you mean we need power?
It's not working you're a liar. You're a goddamn liar is what you are whoa. Hey, okay?
I'm deep in the I'm digging up my God wait a minute wait a minute wait a minute women
Maybe I can build a solar panel. I need cop-out
Jesse you need compound so get in this goddamn cave. No. No I got some here
I don't need to make the work. I got it. How do you have some I?
Stole so much shit. You still worried. We don't have to get back. You goddamn asshole. All right now
I have to should I use it to power or power me. I don't know you boys
I don't know what you're talking about you've already got one so you might as well put it on the the base itself
It's doing something. Yeah a lot of things on the way it was something I
Was right?
newsroom
I'm bringing another research thing back, and then I'm gonna try to find compound elsewhere because alley research is my game up
We're interesting as Ernie
Excuse me, Mr.. Wolfman. This is a co-op game and worried this together
You got me there yeah, I got there so why don't you yeah see I've got a more interesting research here
I'll cover you this is a you said it's a shooter game right? That's what it was
I didn't okay that at all to stop. I can't jump when I'm holding this you asshole
I can't get out of guys well there we go. I got oh, oh yeah, shoot your son
I didn't know that would happen. Oh. Yeah, you didn't know at all. Yeah, you don't know how this game works
I better run while I can
Uh-Huh?
Okay, I'll resin oh good. Yeah, we don't have
as in Resins whoa
why did you put you put the research thing on the smell to power on the
Smelter our on the shelter you didn't put it in the research nation you put it on the smelter
Wait you that's how you learn you waft uh-huh okay? Well while you were wafting
I actually did real research and we've got immediately wind turbine
Yeah, that's from mine
And now I'm going to claim your researchable because you couldn't figure out how to put it in the gosh-darn
Research thing uh uh it's got power wait this isn't even a researchable this isn't really this is just a beach ball
Really? Yeah, it's just this isn't even a research you big goof
Well, I thought it was a big old marvel. Who's a big, Ol marble. Well, I'm going to go here come with me
We're going to go over to the the derelict ship here
And we're gonna see if there's anything of use over there
And then we got to go find compound because if we don't find compound. I'm going to strangle
You like see try look at my speed. Yeah, I don't think I can strangle your giant Bulbous head there. He's off my
Bobblehead uh
And okay, how do you make tethers uh?
What what component it's it's compound again? Oh
We really do need compound
Exactly as I've been saying so excavate this sumbitch here which chief
just keep
Excavating dig it all out, coz there's somebody colorful
I know right, but get the goodies get all the goodies also. You can get materials from plant life
You can get organic stuff and that will eventually be useful for something. I have no idea what though make sounds cool
keep digging I
hate digging
You need what I?
Needed to breathe. I was suffocating
Sorry nothing
Breathing's for the week, you don't know how much I breathe I'm not like
Do you bri are you saying you breathe more than the average person here?
That you got it. Well, then you're not very fit for space are you yeah?
I don't suck up materials like you are suck up air. Yeah, okay
Well under week week ah link. I've noticed this I found the materials inside. We've got
titanium nice
okay, we've got aluminum double nice and
Organic materials, there's other stuff in there, too
But I can't quite get to it jump in that hole I got this ah that's not right
You didn't jump in the hole. I jumped away from well. Can't you get it?
We got to go in from like the bottom which means we gotta excavate it even more this yeah
Oh, God will it follow me fact we have Jessica
It'll do what here I found the ass end of it
I'm trying to go in this oh, I might be stuck in a hole
I know
I'm always stuck gonna hold oh yeah, let me see if I can jump in this thing ah brick hey, hey, okay? I'm good
That's the important part okay. I made it in yeah, that's the important part, okay?
I've got a big it looks like the chair to a vehicle here. Oh
God, so once we build a vehicle. I've got a delightful chair you won't see my chair
Gonna do actually can I do it sure did it? What about you suck on?
I don't know your own stupidity that were your stuff, hahaha
Oh, you got me yeah, I got you good
That's what happens when you do a collab with the old mark Emu you get roasted pretty much
I was loose to it all over. Yeah, whoa did you know that you are a dumb fuck you're sitting in my chair?
Sure, hey, this is not creating me bad. I don't want to carry you back. You find your own way back
What I got I carry your balance nice. Oh yeah, whatever okay? I'm just gonna lay this right?
Oh, God, don't sit in it on you. Oh God fuck you quick
I'm get in the chair get in there
Good job, you did it hey okay? So anyway. That's all the time we got for this episode here
We're gonna pick this up in another episode very soon
So thank you everybody so much for watching let us know how we're doing the comments below
Check out wolfies channel through the link in the description and anything you would like to say before the end
ah
Great. Thanks right everybody and as always. We no go ahead no
I was like yeah, that's good looks it was good
Cool. It's mumbled free and as always. We'll see you in the next